madame tranchant a reçu des lettres de
menaces de mort et hier sa floride a été
saboté c'est à ses invités qui avait
pris sa voiture
bon ok disent vos livres sont bons alors
la boîte à banias plus au moulin
inspecteur principal ou là
[Musique]
le barreau a demandé une enquête rapide
un seul tort moral voilà voilà jean
moulin donc discret
je pense qu'on a affaire à une voiture
je travaille à l'instinct pur
c'est ma méthode monsieur poulat va
devenir notre nouveau majordome
depuis le petit déjeuner tout est à gogo
ou 3,50 en plus à la peine et son prix
mais avec du pain du beurre la sardine
écrasée y apprend mieux
[Applaudissements]
chakra on le port une abomination et à
qui ça arrive ça ça passe pas
[Musique]
oh
vous allez prendre vos bagages et on va
passer par derrière ce sera plus calme
l'assassin et parmi vous
et je vais le débusquer
[Musique]
demandez certainement pourquoi ne tient
sur un taux de la main pas du tout nous
on aimerait jusqu'au bout de lâcher
avant de péter le lustres de murano tués
[Musique]